Now, I know, by the way, I think one of the things Solo told
me was that Destiny was just lying about talking to Rose ever.
And I'm like, "Wait, how do you know that? [laughter]
Wait, how do you know that?"
Little did I realize Solo was like typing, doing the Andrew Tate
under the desk, cupping his balls via text.
No, no, I don't even have a voice changer. I couldn't have talked
to him on the phone. [laughter]
>> Oh, is that a Destiny one? Yeah. No, I I I'm going to
hate all of it. I'm just going to hate it, man. I'm going to
hate it. I'm going to hate it every time. I [music] hate it real
bad. Okay.
I I don't think I can do it. Can't Can't do it, man. Okay.
Let's see here. We got the the court docks. Do I want to do something
before that? I don't think so,
man. Except at some point like we do have to go through the fact
that this guy is still threatening to dox new people. Like he
just threatened to dox esports Batman. So he's threatened to
dox two people who were like big members of his community for
like years, right? He threatened to dox Supreme a couple weeks
ago. Now he's threatening to dox esports Batman
ostensibly for them just being like, I think this guy's got some
problems.
Or maybe maybe they did something way worse. I actually don't
know.
Maybe they did something like infinitely worse. I
I don't know what you could possibly do to justify doxing these
people or I I don't know what they've done that could justify
doxing them. I have no idea. Okay. I don't know, man. I don't
know.
Okay. Anyway, why don't we just get to it? Let's see here. I
again, should we start with his sanctions? I think we probably
have to start with his sanctions to understand Pixie's filings
today. Okay. Oh, also sleep is not fixed. I tried to sleep for
like six hours and got like three hours of sleep again. It's
uh life is rough right now. Okay, sleep's not happening. Sleep
is not occurring.
Let me pull this up here. Here's the destiny document for sanctions.
All right. How long is this? Oh, this is very short. Jesus.
interesting. Oh, this is very redacted,
dude. Okay. On a on a very on just a
on a very real level. Okay.
It's very funny to me
that Destiny filed these sanctions over the Rose testimony
and immediately gets responses that like talk about the Rose
testimony in ways that look horrible for him, right?
Like why would you why even bother? What are these sanctions
going to do? Were you trying to get like Pixie's lawyers like
fined $1,000?
You filed these, you paid thousands of dollars. There's no way
you're going to get them fined as much as you paid Brett to write
this. And then
and then the ultimate outcome is a whole bunch of stuff gets
leaked from those depositions in response to this
that like you definitely don't want in public at all.
I just like I actually don't get it. I I have no idea what is
the calculus.
What could possibly be the calculus here? DG actually thinks
they will get maximum sanctions. I have no idea. Maybe it's really
Maybe what they did is really improper. I actually don't know.
But I just I have no idea why you do this. It's so goofy. What
is What is the underlying like methodology that he's rolling
with here? Like I'm going to say that they they've made a whole
bunch of things about this. I guess we'll we'll take a look.
We'll see.
We'll see. Okay.
I think I've I've stalled long enough. We should just get into
it. Okay, we should just get into it. Matt T, thank you for the
five gifted. Let's go. Let's go. Need more detail on what you
mean. So, these sanctions are about how Pixie referred to something
in a footnote around Rose, right? Like around like she was 17
or something like she was a minor. Destiny was minor exchanging
material with a minor and Destiny basically tries to sanction
her saying this is not true and it's only put in here to harm
him which I'm not sure
it's like there there's some element of that what was the argument
that they were going around. It was basically like, oh, Destiny
had made no good faith effort to find this person and
that
finding her and talking to her was critical to figuring out like
hammering out facts of the case, right? I think that's what it
was. And I was the 17-year-old thing. Was that to say that he
wasn't making a good effort faith to to find her because she
was 17?
Is that what the argument was? I don't remember. It'll say in
here, honestly. I should just get to reading. Give me a second.
Just pull up the foot. Well, the footnote's going to be in here.
Latigious Gamer, right? They're obviously going to reference
the footnote in here. So,
give me a sec. I I need to switch to the judges stuff. Okay.
Doing court docs. We got to do judge judge outfit. Okay. Required.
Required. Actually, you know what? Nah. No. It's unfortunately
this one's like okay, but the wizard is like really well done.
It's like detailed in a way that's way better. It's like way
better, right? I got to stick with the wizard. Even though Even
though I like the judge stuff for court cases, but the the wizard
is cool. I like the wizard. All right. All right. All right.
All right. Let's get to it. Dude, do I have a dark reader that
will work on this?
I don't. Oh well. Oh well.
Very, very bright mode for now.
Let's do it.
Okay. Ah, trying to get comfy. Trying to get comfy. Okay. So,
this is Destiny's sanctions that they put in regarding one of
Pixie's filings. Okay. Defendant Steven K. Benell's motion for
sanctions pursuant to Federal Rules of Civil Procedure 11. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
In her October 3rd, 2025 opposition to defendants's pending motion
to dismiss and for the sole purpose of causing harm to defendant
Steven Kenel II, plaintiff falsely asserted that he exchanged
explicit material with a minor. Specifically, plaintiff claimed
to have identified Rose as blank. the purported recipient of
the video Banell allegedly transmitted in April 2022. Based on
plaintiff's purported investigation, she alleged that Ms. Blank
was a minor at the time she supposedly received the video and
falsely concluded that Banell had exchanged explicit material
with someone who was under 18.
So again,
okay, not only that's very that's I don't know why you would
assert this. Again,
based on the deposition, this is a this is very much it seems
to be what happened. Okay,
th this they're like, "Oh, no. This didn't occur. This occurred.
Therefore, you are a liar,
right? This didn't occur. This is what occurred." So, apparently,
as we go through this, we'll find out that Rose was very aware
these these messages were happening. She was a part of the process.
She like knew it was happening. She knew when she was me making
videos specifically for Destiny that that's who they were for,
right? Like this is so I would say this is still exchanging
material with the minor. You send this material to the minor,
it's forwarded to the minor, the minor sends material, you request
material from the minor, it is forwarded through the middleman
back to you. This is exchanging material with the minor 100%.
It's like not even close.
Anyway,
as we continue, we'll we'll see. Maybe they have Maybe they'll
have good arguments in response to Pixie stuff. We'll see. Maybe
they'll cook in that minor the uh doesn't the minor doesn't get
it forwarded to her. I think Solo keeps it. Oh, I thought I could
have sworn that somebody said Oh, maybe I'm wrong. Hold on. Maybe
I'm wrong. Maybe none of his stuff gets forwarded. Maybe she
doesn't receive Hey, that had changed a little bit on my end.
Okay, if she never received any of the the Destiny material,
it's very possible that could change stuff on my end. Okay. Um,
well, I mean, not a whole lot because he's still requesting material
from a minor and then retaining it after being told she was a
minor. But hey, it changes a little bit. Okay. Based on the Oh,
yes, she's under 18. Not only is Plaintiff's allegation knowingly
and demonstrabably false, but also the age of the purported recipient
of the video is irrelevant to plaintiff's claims and has no bearing
whatsoever on whether this court has subject matter jurisdiction
here.
Uh, that's true.
That is true. But I think it's it's not relevant to the case
itself and whether or not Destiny's liable. It has to do with
I think like assertions made in the motions. Yes.
Right. I don't think it changes anything except assertion like
they're they're responding to an assertion in a motion, I believe.
Anyway, continuing as an initial matter, plaintiff and her council
have been on notice of the falsity of their allegation since
at least October 23rd, 2025, the date of Miss Blank's deposition.
At the deposition, Miss Blank testified that Blank rather, Miss
Miss Blank testified that Blank Bell did not share any explicit
material with Miss Blank or any other minor. In light of this
testimony, I think it's very funny that Destiny helped dox this
person and now when when they're making clear what this person
actually did, what material they actually exchanged, what actually
happened, now they need to redact everything. Destiny when when
this person exists in the world and he has to post her picture,
her major, her school. Also, how did he get all of those things?
One is curious, right?
When he does all of those things, it's very much, oh, this information
needs to be in the public so Kiwi forms can help me find Rose
and then finds out she's a minor. Oh, no, no, no, no. Oh, this
is all blanked out. Actually, Benell did not share any sexually
explicit material. Whip is Oh, also, but if she, let's say Rose
wants that stuff redacted from here because she feels personally
embarrassed by it. I think that's fine. I think that's totally
fine.
Um, and if there was some, you know, although actually, wait,
is Oh,
yeah, I think that's fine. Yeah, I think that's totally fine.
Um, and I think even I would go even further to say that if this
stuff was redacted
at the request of Rose, like let's say she went to her deposition,
she said, "Could you redact details?" And then if Pixie team
were publishing those publicly, ooh, that would look bad. That
would look real bad. Okay. Yikes. Yikes. If that's the case,
just helping Destiny with his arguments. Okay, that would be
real bad. Be really gross.
Okay. Belle did not share any explicit material with Miss Blank
or any other minor. In light of this testimony, Banel demanded
that plaintiff file a notice of Arata and corrected opposition.
Okay. If he didn't send anything to her, if nothing was forwarded
to her, if she never saw any of those videos, that's totally
I I take that back. I retract. Graph is not Listen, the infographic
not correct. I will have to update you. Okay. I'll have to update.
Look. Look. We're actually going to fix it. Hold on. All right.
All right. We're good now. Boom. Updated. Okay. We'll see. We'll
see. Is this as we go through this, we'll see if it's actually
correct or not. Okay. Okay. Despite this demand, plaintiff and
our council have failed and or refused to do so in violation
of their obligations under rule 11. The court should impose appropriate
sanctions. To factual background. On September 19th, 2025, Benell
filed a motion to dismiss the operative complaint on the grounds
that the court lacks subject matter jurisdiction over this dispute
because of the date of the alleged transmission of the video
preceded the or because the date that the v video was transmitted
preceded the effective date of the federal statute which forms
the basis of plaintiff's claims ECF number 132. On October 3rd,
plaintiff filed an opposition to the motion the opposition. In
the opposition, plaintiff falsely asserted that Benell exchanged
explicit material with a minor. Specifically, in a wholly irrelevant
footnote, plaintiff falsely stated that after finally ascertaining
Rose's legal identity, plaintiff has obtained evidence that Rose's
date of birth is October 30th, 2004. Thus, when Banell was exchanging
content with Rose, Rose was uh exchanging content with Rose between
March of 2022 and until October 30th, 2022, Rose was a minor.
Damn.
to support her baseless claim. Plaintiff identified. So I do
find it funny that exchanging they do make it very clear, right?
Themselves Destiny's team makes it very clear here. Hold on.
Don't they
hold on? I I believe this is it's close.
Vanel did not share any explicit material with Ms. Blank or any
other minor.
So, the idea of the exchange is what they're disputing here,
right? You can see how it's sort of artfully done. I'm now upset
that I didn't read this in real time because it would have been
obvious what this was, right? Hey, you
what they what they're doing here, okay, is they're saying, watch
Pixie's team asserted this happened and they're going, "Uh, you
are a disgusting liar. You are a filthy bitch." Because actually,
what happened
is this. You disgusting liar. You're trying to tell me this is
exchanging.
You disgusting [__] I did not send None of my pics
or off videos got to her. Okay, you disgust. Yes, I received
many videos of her in situations, but none of my stuff got to
her. Do you see that? In light of this testimony, Belle demanded
that plaintiff file a notice of a corrected opposition without
So basically say that you were wrong for saying we exchanged.
I sent into a black hole and she sent me I when I requested she
sent me the videos I wanted. Okay.
He's basically he is directly in my opinion admitting to receiving
here in a way that totally contradicts what he said to Willie
Mack, right? Like he just clear now it's very clear that he lied
to Willie Mack. He gas lit his entire audience into saying Willie
Mack was wrong and Willy Mack was making up. But he absolutely
received
Yes. True. Yes. Amazing. You disgusting.
You disgusting.
It's actually this. It's not this. It's this. You disgusting.
Incredible stuff, Stephen. Very cool. Very, very cool, dude.
You can't make it up. You actually can't. You can't make it up.
H amazing. Okay, where were we? Down to here. Sporter BL basless
claim. Plaintiff identified blank as the individual referred
to. Oh, that's too far down. Sorry.
I didn't prep any of this stuff. I just showed up cuz I I just
showed up cuz the docs dropped and it looked funny. Okay,
that's all.
Oh, what's up, fairy queen? How's it going? We're looking. Apparently,
Destiny filed some sanctions against Pixie saying, "Hey, you
said that I exchanged material with a minor, but I did not share
any
You said I exchanged back and forth, but I didn't share any explicit
material with her or any other minor because I sent it to the
middleman and he didn't forward it."
Kind of obviously admitting that he received it himself. Amazing
stuff.
But there's also an opposition after this where Pixie, her lawyers
in opposition to this actually explain what really happened.
And it looks super bad for Destiny. So, we're just going through
it. We're enjoying
Well, I mean, I'm only enjoying because this guy keeps threatening
to dox random former friends of his that are in my community.
And he's made it pretty clear that
uh whether or not I talk about this stuff, he's going to dox
people in my community, constantly threaten to pressure my community.
So, realistically, there's just no downside to me looking at
this stuff anymore. If I don't look at it, nothing happens. If
I look at it, the same thing happens. Okay. Like there's no change
for me backing down in any way. So, might as well just look at
it all. Laugh at it.
On October 3rd, plaintiff filed an opposition to the motion.
But we watch this. We read this. To support her baseless claim,
plaintiff identified Blank as the individual referred to in her
pleadings as Rose. And to demonstrate that Miss Blank was a minor
at the time of the event alleged, plaintiff filed a copy of Ms.
Blank's official certification of Department of Motor Vehicles
driving record as exhibit B to the opposition.
On October 23rd, 2025, plaintiff deposed Miss Blank in Rockford,
Illinois. At a position, Miss Blank testified that this
Okay. Okay. And so she testified to some stuff. Some stuff was
testified to. I do find it interesting that Pixie's team also
gets uh
sorry, Destiny's team also got to depose her. Very funny. Okay,
[clears throat] let's uh let's keep taking a look. DJs are showing
up in force today. Good stuff. Surely some of you guys will hop
in the Discord and discuss. No, no,
maybe not.
Okay. Vanel did not share any content with Miss Blank or any
other minor. Plaintiff and her attorneys know this
So, it sounds like I'm just going to predict that if we ever
see the unredacted pieces of this, it's going to be like Bretler
being like, "Did you ever see this? Have you ever seen this before?
No. Well, checkmate, [__] Checkmate. You've never
seen this
You You never saw his Okay, we're safe. We're safe.
On October 30th, 2025, council for Bedell sent a letter to plaintiff's
council demanding that plaintiff file a notice of Arata and corrected
pleading to retract plaintiff's knowingly false allegation in
her opposition. Brett declaration paragraph 4 and exhibit B.
To date, plaintiffs council has not provided a substantive response
to the letter, nor have they taken any cor of the corrective
action requested.
Rule 11 of the federal rules of civil procedure provides impertinent
part by presenting to the court a pleading, written motion, or
other paper, whether by signing, filing, submitting, or later
advocating it. An attorney certifies that to the best of the
person's knowledge, information, and belief. So basically, you're
not lying, right?
Factual contentions have evidentiary support. The claims defenses
intentions are warranted by existing law or by non-frivolous
argument
is not being presented for any improper purpose such as to harass.
Okay.
All right. Okay.
So, they're basically arguing that they're lying here. Here,
plaintiff's false allegation that Benel exchanged material with
a minor was included for an improper purpose, namely to publicly
humiliate and harass Benel and sway the court's opinion of him.
Critically, the age of the purported recipient of the video has
no bearing whatsoever on Plaintiff's claims in this action, nor
does it have any bearing on whether the court has subject matter
jurisdiction in this case, which is the threshold issue
Okay.
Moreover, plaintiff and her lawyers have been on notice of the
falsity of allegations since previous
Okay. So, they're basically saying you uh they're basically saying
you lied on the like the English,
right? They're saying you you lied. It's not this, it's this.
And what else are they saying? That it's a totally frivolous
argument that it shouldn't be included. So, we'll have to go
and check out what the what the response is. Yeah, give me a
second. Let me pull it. Let me pull it up. Let me pull it up.
So, this is response to 183 and then extension for time of discovery
cutoff.
And then they actually file for their own sanctions, it looks
like. Okay,
motion for sanctions pursuant to I counter your sanctions my
sanctions. Let's go. I don't know, dude. Again, the the calculus
here, I don't even know why you bring this up cuz one, you give
them like a a reason to actually post corrections to anything
you're saying, right? You give them a reason to correct
and then after giving them a reason to
they file their own sanctions. You're you're allowing like you
are participating in this spamming of the docket, right? you're
participating in this with her except it's costing you a money.
I just it just doesn't make any sense to me, but whatever. Okay.
Uh Pixie also filed a or Pixie filed her response to this. No,
not that. Sorry, I'm just trying to God. The sleep thing is going
to get corrected soon. It's got to be rough one today. Okay,
here it is. Here it is. So, this is her response to Destiny's
plea for sanctions. The the motion for sanctions. By the way,
litigating on the docket wouldn't matter if he didn't cover it.
He is the biggest platform for the talk about the minor.
I mean, dude, all I I'm just sitting here like,
man, I
I kind of was getting bored with this stuff.
Can you tell? I I'm like kind of bored by a lot of this stuff.
I I know none of this will ever reach like Destiny's community.
They'll never look at this like honestly in any way. Um I find
it very funny that his number one orbiter is a too that is calling
um that is calling his best friend a and he has to now show support
for the the actual and his best friend. I do wonder how that
fight is all going now, right? Like the actual calling Dan a
Dan obviously doesn't like that. How do you do you guys do we
have any updates on that? How is that going? Is Destiny supporting
the actual or is he supporting his best friend who stood by him
when these allegations dropped? cuz I would assume it's the second
one, but like also maybe he's supporting the who helps him lie
about the case.
This does seem very important to him, right? The case.
Wait, what what did I miss? Oh, Destiny's like best friend on
the internet is an actual Their name is Food Shops. They cover
a lot of this stuff. Okay, so I I'm just curious if if Destiny's
like doing anything there. If he's like helped Dana or if that
person just gets to call Dana and get Destiny's full support.
I think Oh, food shops called into his stream. Oh, very cool.
Very, very cool. Okay, let's check this out. Hold on. Let's check
this out.
Plaintiff Jane Doe's response in opposition to defendants motion
for sanctions pursuant to federal rules of civil procedure 11.
Plaintiff Jane Doe. Plaintiff by through the undersigned council
hereby respectfully opposes defendant Steven K. Benell II's Benel
or defendant. Motion for rule 11 sanctions. Vanel's rule 11 motion
constitutes a textbook example of a frivolous sanctions motion
brought for the sole purpose of harassing and intimidating plaintiff
into withdrawing meritorious claims and or testing the factual
strength or legal sufficiency of plaintiff's claims. Such a tactical
rule 11 motion is itself subject to rule 11 sanctions under well
settled 11th circuit precedent.
Oh, that'll be why they filed their own sanctions, I guess. On
November 13th, 2025, plaintiff served on defense council a cross
motion for rule 11 sanctions for serving a frivolous rule 11
motion on plaintiff. Nevertheless, plaintiff proceeded with filing
for a Oh, so they were talking about this themselves and they're
like, "Hey, if you file that, we're just going to file our own
thing." So, good luck. Interesting.
Neat. Neato. Destiny probably unironically ranks Dan equal to
food shops in terms of friendship because of the depth of his
relationships are friend bucket or enemy bucket. Um, no, that's
actually not true. I don't think that's true at all. I think
probably he ranks food shops higher than Dan because food shops
is willing to lie for him or do whatever and Dan has like slightly
distanced and
yeah
right Dan Dan stopped doing anything else took a break didn't
want to be professionally associated for a little while right
I do think that it's entirely possible that
it's entirely possible that he thinks food shops is like better
he's like more supportive of food chops now he thinks the case
might be dismissed before the end of the year he's getting DG
hyped about up about these docks as a major victory.
Oh, really?
Are they Are they a major victory? Maybe. Um I I legitimately
don't know, man.
I
don't see it personally. I think there's still things that need
to be investigated here. I think he like obviously Pixie still
needs to go through messages. Ultimately, it's just going to
come down to one thing, right? If she can subpoena a Discord,
if she could subpoena a Discord at some point and get messages
related to him.
Because again, I'll say it for everybody so they can all hear
it. If he didn't send this video to anybody else, if he only
sent it before, I don't want him charged extra judicial. Yeah.
Extrajudicially, okay? Like, I don't want him to lose this case
even though he didn't actually do the thing.
So, it's really about him or about Pixie getting like the DMs
and being able to go through them and then or her lawyers be
able to go through them and then just seeing if he actually sent
the video to somebody else. That's all, you know? That's it.
That's it. Okay. Is there a reason to think Discord has the log
still? He deleted them all immediately. And I'm not sure so sure
Discord just holds on to that stuff indefinitely. They definitely
don't. But uh what Pixie team would have done was a like you
can do a
what do you call it? Like a thing to ask Discord to you can request
that they retain. You can do like a retention request. Okay.
Basically, hey, we're seeking a subpoena. So, we're asking for
you to retain the logs. I thought he handed them over. Well,
he handled his he handed his version over, but they're all like
mutable logs that have no uh what do you call it? Chain of custody,
right? So, they'll have to go to Discord. I assume, listen, I
assume he didn't hand over logs. If he was if he was guilty,
I assume he would have modified that evidence. Yes.
Compliance request. No, no, no. A retention request. So, there's
two steps here. You would ask the platform to retain data based
on somebody and saying, "We're seeking a subpoena, looking to
get data from this person in a legal matter." And but because
we cannot yet have that subpoena, the court case is just starting.
We haven't gotten it yet. Please retain the the information like
if you have a data deletion policy, let's say you get rid of
deleted data, somebody deletes all their messages, you get rid
of that after 30 days. I think that's Discord's policy. What
you do is you file a retention request with them and you say,
"Can you hold on to that for me cuz I'm currently seeking like
a legal action against this person?" Or the cops go and say,
"We're trying to charge this person, so retain the data until
we can get a warrant."
You know, that's it. Um, Discord can hold on to this stuff for
up to a year, I think.
I think up to a year. So, you're probably getting close if she
hasn't gotten a subpoena yet.
And then I think
if they don't get that subpoena, I'd put it at like 955. Destiny
wins eventually. I still don't I think it's closer to like 50/50
that it gets dismissed on subject matter jurisdiction grounds.
I don't think it does, but again, it it might. It's possible.
Um, if if Abby wouldn't sit for a deposition with any of these
people, I think that could be an issue. Possibly. I although
I don't know if if you asked to depose somebody and they're like
your core witness for like retaining subject matter jurisdiction,
I don't know if things can be dismissed on those grounds, right?
Like I think the fact that she gave a
an affidavit, like Abby gave an affidavit, I think that holds
until like trial. You basically say I'll I'll testify to this
under oath. I don't know if that gives you the right to depose
them immediately. It might. Like if you can subpoena them, it
might. But if you can subpoena them, if you can't find them,
I don't know if that means that you
I don't know if that means it gets dismissed. I I just don't
know. We'll see. Should it be over for Discord to hold on to
those logs by now then? No. No. Destiny didn't delete them until
January of 2024.
Sorry, 2025. And we're a month away from
So,
uh I they also might have gotten them already. I have no idea.
I literally don't know. Don't know, man. Yeah, I've got no idea.
Uh, the strategic yet frivolous nature of Banell's motion is
substantiated by several factors. First, Banell declined to raise
his objections. In his reply to the fraction of the response
to the motion to dismiss, he now attacks.
To raise his objections.
Okay, so they didn't actually even object to that at all in their
in their response. I don't know if they have to. I I literally
don't know. Second, Banell's protestations are belied by the
evidence aduced to date by even the fact uh even by the fact
that Banell himself referred to these the exchanges described
in the disputed footnote in the identical manner in which plaintiff
did. Third, Banell's objections are patently premature. By way
of example, as of the time of Benell's rule 11 motion was as
of the time Benell's rule 11 motion was served, Banell has yet
to sit for deposition, including to testify about the events
in question. At most, Benell might opt to raise his objections
in a motion for summary judgement or motion in lame at the appropriate
juncture, or he could have just moved to strike. Fourth, rule
11 is not designed to resolve a disputed factual issue raised
in a single footnote of a response, which would be unnec which
would unnecessarily increase the cost of litigation. Fifth, Banell's
rule 11 motion is devoid of any legal discussion about the relevance
of similar acts by Banell. Coupled with the unsupportable nature
of his factual contentions, Banell's arguments amount to no more
than a conclusory and misleading contentions. or two
uh no more than conclusory and misleading contentions. Got it.
Rule 11 sanctions are warranted to deter repetition of Banel's
improper
Okay, so they're basically saying,
oh my
God, this stuff is a lot. Pronounced lemony. Lemony.
Okay, cool. All right,
keep going.
Rule 11 is intended to deter claims with no factual or legal
basis at all. Creative claims coupled with even with ambiguous
or inconsequential facts may merit dismissal but not punishment.
Oh
wait, really? Okay.
So basically, you can't sanction us for this obviously, but you
can like move to strike them or move to get them dismissed. So
you could say we need to remove that or something. Yeah, but
you can't actually sanction us for this. Okay, I'll say the way
that's the way that's written. Creative claims. That doesn't
make them sound good, does it?
Creative claims. We just had a little creative claim there. Okay,
we'll see. We'll see.
All right. Argument. Banel's rule of emotion is an improper attempt
to convert factual disputes over the merits of her claims into
a sanctions dispute. Banell's characterization of the facts is
misleading. as an initial matter. It should be noted that Benell
does not actually dispute that blank blank screen named Rose
here and after referred to as Rose was a minor when materials
were exchanged prior to her October 2022 birthday just as plaintiff
accurately noted in the footnote. Doc entry 183 at 16 defended
arguing rather that Rose's age is immaterial in Huh. Okay. So
he didn't actually dispute that she was a minor. She didn't say
that's when they when they disputed that part of the thing. When
they filed their motion to
uh
in opposition, when they filed their motion in opposition, they
said, "Actually, her age is irrelevant." They didn't say, "Oh,
no, she's not a minor. That's wrong. You're lying."
Okay. Indeed, Banell was apparently concerned enough about Rose
having been a minor at the time that he raised the issue at her
deposition. A fact fails to disclose in his rule of emotion.
Exhibit A to the declaration of Carlos Garcia Perez filed concurrently
herewith to be filed under seal at 74710.
Moreover, in his reply to plaintiff's motion to dismiss, Banell
himself generally refers to exchanges exchanges of such materials
between Bellanell and Rose in the same manner plaintiff did in
the footnote and tellingly raised no such objection to the footnote
therein. Documentary 149 at 1410. It is patently clear that Benell's
argument boils down to an objection to the relevance of Rose's
age at the time. And he bases this objection on representations
to this court, which are however anything but undisputed. I don't
I think uh no, I think his dispute is I think this is his dispute.
Again, I think this is his dispute. You're you're implying this,
but actually this I think that's what the dispute is. Okay, we'll
see. But I think that's the dispute actually. Okay. Specifically,
Banell posits that the fact that Rose was a minor is irrelevant
because one, Rose's then boyfriend Solo was catfishing Banell.
Two, Rose was not directly operating the social media account
through which the materials were exchanged, and three, Rose did
not see any of the plaintiff's materials, documentary 183 at
1 and 3 and 4. Despite the fact that it is patently improper
to force plaintiff to litigate these highly disputed factual
issues at this stage of the case for the reasons set forth in
sections two and three infra plaintiff addresses why Benell's
contentions are problematic. Okay. So basically hey these are
like for we can litigate these factual claims like somewhere
but you know a a sanctions motion is it's an improper place to
do it. We shouldn't litigate these here. Banel admits, for example,
that Rose also testified that Solo shared with her materials
Banell sent to Rose over the imposttor account. See exhibit A
at 35 uh 1216 36510 and at 36 11:15 Rose admitting she was shown
a handful of videos that Destiny sent via the imposttor account.
Oh. Oh. Uhoh. Wait, what? Uhoh.
So his So like Destiny the whole time was like, "Oh, listen.
This is going to get really crazy, guys, cuz there's a trafficker
doing this, right? There's a trafficker doing this the whole
time. And like,
you don't even know what's going on, right? Time to update the
chart again. Wait, what do you mean? Isn't this Isn't this correct?
Is this not correct? Imposter account is a matter to be decided
at court. Well, okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did I miss
this? What? Hold on. What did I say here? Oh,
admits, for example, that Rose also Oh, yeah. Okay. So, yeah.
Sorry. We do need to fix the chart. The chart is this. Oh, maybe
they're not disputing that then. Maybe I'm wrong. So, they're
arguing the chart is this and that she testified that the chart
is this.
Oh boy.
Oh boy. Sorry. I read that backwards in my mind. I read that
backwards actually. Oh boy. Oh no. So Vanel admits, for example,
that Rose also testified that Solo shared her materials Vanel
sent to Rose over the imposttor account. So yes, it was forwarded.
Okay, that's why. Dude, that's what I thought I saw. I could
have sworn I saw that like this paragraph. So Rose basically
it sounds like Rose is arguing that she was doing this this work
for this person and he was managing the social media accounts,
That's that sounds like the arrangement they had going on. This
would be trafficking,
right? I believe like trafficking of a minor.
I I because trafficking would be like with dubious consent, right?
Obviously the minor you can't have consent. So, trafficking of
a minor exhibit A and add this. Rose admitting she was shown
a handful of videos that Destiny sent via the imposttor account.
Oh boy. Rose also testified that Solo shared with her the Discord
messages exchanged with Banel and that she knew that the explicit
images and videos that she took of herself and with other individuals
would be provided to Banell. Okay, this is all very funny. This
is very interesting.
Now, I'm I'm going to tell you what I said before, and I actually
know the answer to this, but when I read this paragraph for the
first time, okay, when I saw this,
when I read this paragraph for the first
my first thought is, okay, so like
she's like aware of Destiny and all of this. This explains exactly
like why how she got the merch and stuff. Now, I really need
to know who bought that shirt. who bought that shirt in the picture
when Destiny decided he was going to dox Rose to Kiwi Farms when
he was going to help them dox, right? He he posted a whole bunch
of private information, unique unique PII about her that could
be used to identify her. When he did that,
he posted a picture of her wearing a DG shirt with no pants,
right? Like you you ever see a girl wear your oversized shirt
and it's like a like a mini dress. That's like this that was
going on. Okay, she was wearing a DG shirt like that. And he
posted that picture for everybody to see. And that is the picture
that they actually used to find her. By the way, that they had
never been able to use the reverse image search software to find
her. And that was the facial picture that people found eventually
found was actually used to reverse image and find reverse image
search and find her. So that picture was critical in actually
figuring out who Rose was and doxing her apparently.
So W Destiny, right? W Destiny.
But I I was always curious like if he if she bought that shirt
then he should have been able to find her right away and talk
to her. And if Solo bought that shirt then he probably knows
who Solo is. He probably could figure out who Solo is, right?
You'd go find around that time
almost certainly.
So like how can he possibly virtue signal if he's never gone
and looked for that person's information? How can he possibly
virtue signal about how anybody else is protecting Solo or or
any like what is that? What is that about?
I believe he gets asked about this on stream today. So, I'm looking
forward to that. Seeing his response to that. Okay. Should be
very interesting.
let's keep looking. Oh, also not had any water yet today, like
before the stream. So, already had like a full liter of water
and I'm going to have to have more cuz I Holy moly
today. He has everything on solo by the way. New stance. Oh,
wait.
Hold on.
Oh, no. Not again. Sorry. Somebody get me the le tweet. I need
the le tweet. Where's his response to Ellie? Hold on. Let me
see if I can find it. Cuz a couple months ago, this was the stance.
Okay. If she was a legit minor, can you tell me why no one seems
to care that Solo is legitimately trafficking her and using her
to honeypot people? Those are federal felonies, by the way. Actually,
I've been thinking this over. I would like to see the police
look into this if for no other reason than he could be exploiting
other girls. Only one of us can make that happen. Want redemption,
Stephen? Go to the police tomorrow and give them everything you
have. I HAVE NOTHING TO GIVE THEM. I HAVE NOTHING to give them,
dude.
Dude.
Uh, I have nothing to give them. Remember? Oh, I forgot. He also
says that he was he actually tried to get Kiwi Farms to dox her.
I have nothing to give them. Remember, the only reason they even
found the rose person was because I posted the pics in chat to
bait them into looking. Seems pretty stupid to do that if I thought
she was 17, huh? Wonder if any of them will spend half the effort
looking for this child trafficker while having all of the information
on the child trafficker that he's not giving. Bro, WHY DID YOU
DOX Rose and not the child sex trafficker then? Hold on. You
doxed Rose and not the child sex trafficker. You objectively
wanted to harass Rose more than find the child sex trafficker.
Yes,
you've got all this information on Solo and you're not just publishing
it, bro. You're doxing people in my Discord who are your former
friends who are like, "This guy needs help. This guy's not okay."
You're you're threatening to dox and doxing those people, okay?
and not
Like not that not that doxing is like ever cool, but it kind
of is cool in the case of like a child trafficker. Like actually,
you know what? I'm going to stand on business and say w doxing
child sex traffickers. I maybe you know, yeah, I think so. You
know, you got a you got a lot of evidence that this person is
a child sex trafficker. And I think there there seems to be quite
a bit piling up. Why? Why were you so quick to dox Rose? So quick
to try to dox me, Queman, a whole bunch of other people, but
you won't dox the child trafficker. What?
What? I don't Huh.
Could it possibly be he does didn't know then but does know now?
Well, I mean, he had more information to give to people regardless.
And we were asking this question consistently at this time, right?
This was already a question everybody was asking. Hey, uh, she's
wearing your merch. Doesn't that mean you have somebody's information?
either hers or the uh or the child traffickers like one of the
two.
He was aware of the question. Okay. All right.
We keep looking. Okay. Benelli admits that he that the videos
were sent to Rose, so they were exchanged. So, it is it is this.
We've we've actually achieved this. I'm glad that this wasn't
incorrect and we could just go back to this. Okay. All right.
Very good. Rose also testified that Solo shared with her the
Discord messages exchanged with Banell and that she knew that
the explicit images and videos that she took of herself and with
other individuals would be provided to Banell.
Rose further testified that she did not know the plaintiff.
Uh this is an this is important because if Rose did does not
know the plaintiff, she could not know one way or another whether
one of the handful of videos that Destiny sent depicted plaintiff.
Based on these facts, the question whether Rose ever saw plaintiff's
materials is anything but undisputed.
Rule 11 sanctions against Benell are warranted for exhibiting
a deliberate indifference to obvious facts. Okay. Oh, wait. Did
he try? Oh, so he h
Oh. OH, WAIT.
Did I miss Were they trying to argue that like
Oh, are they trying to argue that Rose isn't relevant to the
case because she never saw the videos of Pixie?
Oh,
well that's goofy,
huh?
Okay. Interesting. So, I guess
Oh, that's bizarre. Now, now I'm like I see. So, the the factual
So, the the dispute here will be
Rose doesn't remember if she was sent the video of Pixie by Solo,
if that was like further forwarded on or Desi's going to say
that that doesn't um that doesn't count as him sending it. So
this person's actually not like relevant to the case.
Okay,
that's like a total I I mean legally maybe he could get that
through, right? He's saying that this basically creates um that
while while this doesn't like excalpate him from retaining material,
right? He he did still retain
obviously
that now he sent this material to somebody who had Now I guess
the question would be did Rose have the account? Did Rose have
access to the account and was it forwarded on? Because does that
now make this guy the person who shared the material right with
this person? I actually don't know how this works necessarily,
right? Cuz this person wouldn't have had knowledge. So is this
not man? How does that work legally? That's actually a isn't
it? So basically who's responsible here? But for Destiny sharing
with this person, it could never be
leaked, right? And it couldn't possibly be sent to this person.
So, let's say hypothetically it was sent to this person, right?
The the Pixie video.
Is that a violation on Destiny's part or not,
right? Cuz cuz only by sending to this person who was forwarding
the material onto this person and Destiny thought he was sending
it to this person and so but for him sending it, it couldn't
have been forwarded forward,
So, I'm saying but it obviously is still a disputed fact whether
or not she had seen the Pixie video. But if she did, let's say
it did happen. Could Desessie be held responsible or would that
person be relevant to the case here? I actually don't know. I
I literally don't know. It's like a interesting ponderable.
Yeah, I don't know the law there. Why would the middleman send
it to Rose? What's the point? Well, it depends on what this guy
is, right? Is this guy like a Is this guy like a social media
manager who's like, "Oh, you have a really big person who's like
interested in your stuff. like we should probably keep this like
big should probably keep this like pay pee on the hook so I'm
going to involve you in this is that like what was going on right
like I assume people are like oh this is like a you're people
are imagining this is like a 50-year-old fat dude in a in a basement
somewhere right this middleman
but like we don't actually know
yeah we don't actually know right we don't know what this person's
age is we don't know what they're doing with anything we we have
no idea who they are at all right kind It doesn't matter because
of the evidence coming out is more of the issue now. The civil
case is quickly taking a backseat to other
I mean maybe, but it's very interesting. Weren't they in a relationship?
Yeah, but I think we'll see if this gets mentioned. I think they're
still arguing that this per Sorry, not this person that this
person is like in Europe or something. We'll see if that gets
addressed here at all cuz they keep Destiny keeps saying like
international sex trafficker.
So, I'm actually not totally sure. Oh, well, we're learning as
we go. Give me a second. Just got to check some messages real
quick. Make sure I'm not missing
Make sure I'm not missing anything.
I'm not. I'm good.
If Solo is 172, does he get in trouble, too? Well, I mean, I
guess that would then make it so he was sending it to Solo. And
I mean, nothing changes there, right? No. No. For this case,
I don't think anything changes.
It's basically for for this. I'm I'm just arguing whether or
not Rose could be like a person material to the case or if she
could testify on
like even if she did receive the Pixie video, is that necessarily
something that could be blamed on Destiny or does it have to
be blamed on this person?
Right. So, so as and then is Rose's like testimony valid or relevant
would be the question. Like is her all of her testimony irrelevant
because she never saw the Pixie video? she actually is not party
to the case like at all. Right?
That's that's probably what's going on here. And then he could
say, "Oh, well, I want this all stricken from the the case going
forward."
But to be fair for everybody, including Destiny, they thought
this was the they thought this was the case before. Yes. So like
this still all had to be litigated. It still all had to be put
out there. Um but then for Pixie's case, none of Destiny's transgressions
changed because he just sent it to somebody else. It's just this
person you'd have to depose. So, I guess they're going to go
have to have to go depose this person now. And Destiny knows
who it is.
And I wonder why. There's no way he has like all the information
on this person, right? Wait, is this Hold on cuz I'm like going
back and I'm going back and thinking I see references in the
Discord. I don't follow like a lot of the case, but did Destiny
talk about like a second international subpoena they were trying
to get to like extend the case or something? Is that just they're
trying to get like solo to?
Yeah, middleman is solo here. Hold on. Do this. Wouldn't she
still be relevant in relation to any sort of implied consent
argument since he was saying her he was close to her? Um, no.
I don't think so. I just So, but this doesn't change like Pixie's
right to run the case. It doesn't change anything. It just might
change whether or not like Rose is the person you actually care
about any of the But then if that's the case, if Rose is irrelevant
and Rose wasn't getting this stuff. Actually, her testimony on
like
on a couple of things might be thrown out. I do wonder. I uh
Nothing. Uh no, that can't be the case. Allegedly. Allegedly.
Sure. Isn't it Molina? So, they were trying to depose Molina,
but I thought I'd heard about a second international subpoena
they were trying to get. No. Am I wrong?
I don't think I'm wrong on that. I think I'm right on that. I
think I'm correct on that. Oh well.
Okay, here we go. Okay.
So, furthermore, Rose's testimony also reveals that because A,
she was aware of Banel being catfished through the imposttor
account and that explicit materials of her would be shared with
Banel. Banell was making requests for explicit materials. Uh-oh,
And that C materials were being shared in this manner and then
at times shown to her. She was at least indirectly communicating
with Banell. Yeah, absolutely. Uh, thus the footnote stating
that Banell was exchanging material with a minor is not incorrect.
The fact that Soul acted as a go-between does not alter this
assertion. The fact remains that Banell requested explicit material
of a minor and that the minor provided it for him and he received
it and viewed it. Yes. Yeah. Obviously. Yeah. Well, I will say
at least morally as much as as much as Desessie's like a totally
morally bankrupt person, morally he is still under the impression
at this point that she is 19, right? Now,
he didn't do a lot to look into that. There's a lot of red flags
there. A whole lot of red flags there. Okay. But he at least
ostensibly is like the plausible deniability of she told me she
was 19 and I had no idea otherwise, right?
Or 18. Sure. 18. Okay. He hopes that this is BS.
Uh, no it's not. Not if I mean if she testified she saw like
videos of Destiny or videos Destiny sent her, then it's not.
He is he's exchanging videos with this person. I mean, you could
change it to he is exchanging
material with a minor through a child trafficker, right? He is
like going to somebody who pimps out minors and exchanging material
with that person and like with the minor via that person. So
you could be more accurate. I think Pixie's team should file
an Ara making that clear that Destiny did not exchange that he
exchanged material materials with a minor via a go between.
Yeah, I think so.
And while Rose repeatedly testified that she did not message,
now I know, by the way, I think one of the things Solo told me
was that Deste was just lying about talking to Rose ever. And
I'm like, wait, how do you know that? [laughter]
Wait, how do you know that?
Little did I realize Solo was like typing doing the Andrew Tate
under the desk cupping his balls via text.
No. No. I don't even have a voice changer. I couldn't have talked
to him on the phone. [laughter]
Oh boy. Uh-oh. Very funny stuff. Okay. While Rose repeatedly
testified that she did not message Benel uh message directly
with Banel, she also testified that she did not recall whether
she ever spoke to him via other means. Uh I honestly don't remember
if I ever called
Moreover, Banell produced in his case his communications with
an individual with the screen named Straight Raid, which included
a message on November 29th, 2024, in which he states that he
had a decent length phone calls with Rose multiple times about
both of our personal things, never had a problem, issue, fight
over literally anything.
Okay.
Can we just point to the the fact that when he sent the Pixie
video, I believe he'd been in communication with this account
for a week, right? A week and a half. And this was a totally
insane liar. He He just openly lied here. He just obviously openly
lied to try to get Pixie to feel sorry for him, to try to get
Pixie to forgive him. It's just a clear and obvious lie. Like
he he represented this as like a close friendship for a long
period of time, which okay, maybe after a while it was, but when
you sent the video, you'd known her for 10 days. 9 days. We we
believe it's 9 days. We don't know the exact amount. Okay. We
don't know exactly when they started messaging on Twitter. Uh,
bro, he said solo be using some high-tech voice changer like
the ninja in Mission Impossible.
Okay. Okay. Very interesting.
See exhibit C here too to be filed under seal. As such, Banell's
claim that he never communicated with Rose, including when she
was a minor, is misleading and belied by the record. Okay. All
right. I honestly don't remember if I ever called
Okay. And Destiny said he communicated with her. Interesting,
dude. the amount of times it's going to be so funny. The the
the
video essaist who puts this together like all of Destiny's flip-flops
over time, they're going to have such a banger video, right?
There's like a there's like a 5 million view video sitting in
all of Destiny's flip-flops as this case has gone along. It's
so funny to watch. Okay, it's it's going to be so funny. I don't
know if Pixie will ever get justice for what was done to her.
I don't know if she'll win this. sure doesn't seem good right
now, right? Like I don't think she's in a position to win this
case at the moment with the stuff that's publicly filed now.
Could go to court and things could change. I don't know. But
I'm just saying I feel like Destiny's just like burned everything
over this
Justice, she never had a case. Um, hold on. Trip to pound town.
Just so just so we're clear,
Destiny violated every single element of
He just did it before it was on the books. Like like realistically,
justice is a moral concept. It is not always a legal concept,
right? We call it the justice system. It's so you can seek justice.
You don't always get justice through the justice system.
You know, that's all.
Like she obviously was wronged. I don't think anybody's sitting
here saying she wasn't wronged. So, she never had a case. I mean,
she she has some idea of a case. She has every right to file
a case. If it if it comes out that she that Destiny never sent
the video to anyone else, then yeah, I think she shouldn't get
any monetary compensation under this statute. She's still filing
under other statutes. I don't know if she'll get those either,
to be honest. Those seem weaker.
Anyway,
I know you guys want me to put on the Death Note music. I'll
put on the Death Note music when we review the Desty stuff. Okay.
Um, she's going after the wrong person. No, she's going after
the person who violated her trust. You're just wrong trip to
pound town, but it's okay. You're you're just totally wrong,
right? She didn't trust Solo with her with her videos. She didn't
trust Solo with any of the stuff. You're totally Destiny's going
after the wrong person. Destiny is not going after the person
who leaked any of his information. Destiny's protecting the person
who leaked all of his information. I don't know why. It's very
I I don't know why he felt it more helpful to Doc Rose than it
was to Doc
I I I actually don't know why. It's very interesting. It's very
confusing.
Uh, I would love to know what's going on in his head. Rose is
the founder badge. Yeah, it would have been a lot of DG people
who started with the stream, you know. Okay, let's continue.
The evidence shows that Rose was also victimized by Benell through
doxing ID at 431-8
and that despite suspecting Rose was a minor, see exhibit B here
too to be filed under seal, he tried to send a group of guys
to find her because he wanted to talk to her at 4255-12.
See, also there was like a Discord chat that Banell put together
and wanted to find Rose, which was me, I guess. And basically,
these people found out all kinds of information on me as possible.
Oh, well, cool.
Very neat.
Now, I will say I will say that might be hearsay. I don't know
if she knows more than we do online. I actually don't know. Okay,
she might only know what we know about that Discord group existing.
Okay,
that might be it. Anyway, while it is un Let's see here. While
it is understandable that Banell seeks to have these disturbing
facts stricken from the record, his rule 11 motion represents
a transparent attempt to intimidate plaintiff into withdrawing
her meritorious allegations. Such bad faith tactics warn sanctions
against Benell and his council. Rule 11 prohibits conversion
of factual disputes into a sanctions dispute. Courts have routinely
held that rule 11 motion of targeting a factual dispute represents
an improper attempt to convert a dispute over the factual allegations
and legal arguments in plaintiff's complaint into a sanctions
dispute.
Okay, I'm going to go ahead and say I don't care about the the
precedents and stuff on this. I'm just going to assume these
precedents are somewhat valid. I don't usually do that. Usually
I'd look into them, but realistically I again I'm kind of like
done with the case covering this more from a content point of
view. Destiny admitted to that group himself after the will.
Oh, right. He did. True. He totally did, right?
I forgot about that. I wonder if he'd admit to like that group
feeling really uncomfortable with him sharing possible with them
cuz that was a part of some of the leaks that happened. Right.
Okay. Rule 11 prohibits conversion of factual disputes into a
sanctions dispute. Yes.
[clears throat] Banel's rule 11 motion is designed to harass
plaintiff and pressure her into abandoning relevant claims.
I don't think so.
I
I kind of understand why they write this. I
I don't know if it's relevant that Rose is a minor. Let's see.
Let's read their argument for why it's relevant. Okay. Rule 11
sanctions against Banell and his council of record are warranted
because of the purpose of Benell's rule of emotion to clearly
is
because the purpose of Banel's rule of emotion is clearly to
harass plaintiff and pressure her into abandoning claims against
him by voluntarily striking them from her opposition. I'll just
say like, okay, Pixie is like filing this stuff and I don't know
if that's relevant, but I don't have a lot of, you know, I don't
know if it's irrelevant. I think you could like argue it's relevant.
Some of the footnote stuff, right? I think you could argue it's
relevant if you're saying, "Oh, this is why he like refused to
look into these things or whatever."
You could probably say it's like relevant to those arguments.
And realistically, Destiny's just not doing his harassment through
the court system. He's doing it like he's not well he was earlier
doing it through filings but like Desi docs what Pixie's wife
he's just totally psychotic in like every way
like I'm sorry I'm sorry man
it's total total nut job you not know about that
Pixie's wife yeah Pixie had like a green card marriage [clears throat]
hold on Pixie had like a green card marriage or something And
I believe that person lived in Destiny's building and like yelled
at her at some point. And so Destiny basically leaked the messages
of Pixie saying it was a green card marriage and then doxed the
person and said you should call ICE on the person. But don't
you know she yelled. I do know that. I just said I forgot about
it. I forgot. Oh, I forgot to put it point it out was all pixie
credibility tanking.
Um, man, I just
Okay, so uh, previously I'd said Desi's put on the record multiple
times that his marriage to Molina was a green card marriage.
And I when he heard that the first time, HE GOES, "WHAT? I MARRIED
MOLINA BECAUSE I LOVE MY WIFE." It's like, okay, like I understand
that that is a part of it. you like Molina, but you made it very
clear on multiple occasions that you never thought you would
get married, that you didn't want to get married, but you got
married so she could come back to the country cuz your relationship
wasn't going to work otherwise. You got it as like a stop gap
on what was otherwise going to be a breakup. It wasn't like a
meaningful marriage. I'm not saying you didn't love her, but
you literally explained on the record multiple times that it
wasn't about love. That wasn't why you got married. That you
did care about her, but you thought the relationship wasn't going
to work unless you she was over here and she had to get a green
card to do that. It's like different. That's obviously different.
Like he's basically on the record saying, "I would never have
gotten married if not to get a green card for Molina." Did she
get a green card? I think she abandoned it. But it's still fraud
to start the process without like like just explicitly getting
married because you want the green card, right?
But whatever. We're not trying to stay consistent here. We're
just trying to flip-flop all over the place. Okay. Oh my goodness.
I need more water. Me, dude. Reading sucks. Reading this sucks.
Okay.
Hold on. What am I doing? I need also more upbeat music cuz Jesus
Christ, this is like way too chill. I need like some actual music
that's going to keep me awake. Okay, give me a second. I'm getting
water. Okay, we're back. Rule 11 sanctions against Benell and
his council of record are warranted because of the purpose because
the purpose of Banel's rule 11 motion is clearly to harass plaintiff
and pressure her into abandoning claims against him by voluntarily
striking them from her opposition, thereby demanding that she
wave her right to raise these issues. As noted, a careful review
of his rule 11 arguments reveals that Banell does not in fact
dispute that Rose was a minor when materials were exchanged.
The question whether this fact is relevant has yet to be litigated.
And Banell cannot escape the reality by bullying plaintiff with
a baseless with baseless rule 11 threats. As such, Banell's motion
was filed for an improper purpose, including to harass plaintiff
and needlessly increase the cost of litigation. While Banell
is expected to argue that Rose's testimony was aduced after the
briefing on the motion to dismiss was completed, this does not
render his conduct in bringing his rule 11 motion any less egregious.
Banell's objection is that these allegations against him are
false, which he could have but declined to contest by submitting
a declaration. But the underlying time timeliness issue also
further underscores that rule 11 was not designed to threaten
a sanction. every time some evidence is aduced during discovery
that one party can attempt to frame a certain way. If that were
permitted, litigants would bring hundreds of rule of emotions
on a rolling basis. See, that seems relevant to me, right? Like
basically, if you put something in a in a ruling that's like
a creative argument, you're like trying to put together an argument
and it's based on somebody's testimony, right? [clears throat]
And they go, "Hey, that hasn't been litigated yet. You can't
say that." Like, "No, that's not true. What the [__]
They said that. Of course, I could say it.
You might disagree, but like litigate that via motions. Don't
litigate that via sanctions. That's
like it's a it's a it's a factual dispute that's up in the air.
Why the hell would you use sanctions to litigate it? Are you
dumb? I that makes sense,
right? Because then then you could go back through this case
and there probably are dozens of places where rule 11 sanctions
could apply,
right? I would imagine.
Wouldn't rule sanction wouldn't rule 11 sanctions apply in the
in like other cases where Destiny's referenced Rose's testimony
as well?
Like, hey, despite that testimony being there, like this still
is not a like relevant or sorry, this is not like a decided fact
yet. Okay. I don't know the rules. Well, I'm saying this based
on the fact that
with these uh with this I'm I'm assuming this one is strong.
So, it's the uh what is it?
It's the this president, right?
Which president is it? It's the one they they cited right at
the beginning. Yeah. Well settled 11th circuit precedent is using
it to test like the legal strength or legal sufficiency of claims
is not valid. You you need to actually oppose them and then I
guess if they were maintained after they were opposed and litigated,
then you could sanction somebody if if they refuse to back down
from that claim or something along these lines.
But that's just what I'm imagining, dude. I don't know. Uh, irrespective
of the veracity of Banel's factual contentions, rule 11 is not
the vehicle, the proper vehicle for resolving a disputed footnote
remark.
Basically, just a ton of procedural stuff. Okay. Don't super
care about the procedural stuff to be honest with you. Relevance
of Benell's misconduct. Plaintiff also briefly addresses the
question of relevance of similar instances of Benell's misconduct
to this to this case. Though again, this question would be more
appropriately addressed through other vehicles after the close
of discovery. First, there is no dispute that Benell's conduct
surrounding Rose is squarely alleged in the complaint and thus
highly relevant to Plinto's allegations. Documentary entry 120
at paragraphs 1213
15 26 3139. To the extent that Banell disputes the relevance
of of Banell's conduct towards another victim who is not a plaintiff,
such evidence is equally relevant so long as plaintiff does not
utilize evidence of similar wrongful acts to prove his character
or propensity to act in conformity therewith. And Biden has not
asserted that plaintiff did attempt to make such a showing. So,
this is basically the idea that you're using this as character
evidence. That's that hasn't happened. Basically, there are a
whole bunch of factual disputes happening. You've engaged with
these. I do think
Oh, man. I do think like engaging with a bunch of these as factual
disputes before filing your sanctions. That probably hurts you
a little bit, right?
Got to got to hurt you a little bit. Okay. More specifically,
rule 404b1
provides that while evidence of crimes, wrongs, and other acts
is not advisible to prove the character of a person in order
to show action on the inconformity therewith. So, you can't say
this person has raped 12 people, therefore they are guilty of
raping a 13th person, right? You can never do that. You can't
show character evidence that is just slowly like beating up on
uh
you can't just show character evidence that somebody has committed
a bunch of crimes. this is that that that's somehow going to
make a jury more likely because juries will be susceptible to
that. So, if you're actually using character evidence to to weaken
some or to make it seem like somebody's more guilty, they'll
get rid of that, right? There's a there's a specific thing. It's
basically like if it if it helps the case less than it prejudices
a jury, it's supposed to be thrown out. That's like the standard,
right?
Uh it may however be admissible for other purposes such as proof
of motive, opportunity, intent, preparation, plan, knowledge,
identity, absence of mistake or lack of accident.
Okay. The list is not intended to be exhausted for a range of
relevancy outside the ban is almost infinite.
Uh nor
citations and general quotation marks are omitted. Nor are the
stated categories mutually exclusive and include for example
a showing of consciousness of guilt
and to corroborate crucial testimony. In this context, a showing
of clear and convincing evidence is not necessary. Additionally,
under the statute, plaintiff invokes in the case at bar prior
instances of cyber harassment are plainly relevant.
Uh person who has one prior conviction for cyber harassment and
who commits a second or subsequent cyber harassment commits a
felony in the third degree punishable. This is for the Florida
state courts. Well, Benell never disputed any of the foregoing
in his conclusory rule of emotion. He if he ever chooses to do
so, eg in a motion for lemine uh lemonade lemony lemony, it is
equally well settled that a curative instruction ordinarily resolves
any concerns of prejudice.
Okay. So the judge can basically say here's how you have to frame
it, right? I think that's what they're saying. A judge basically
if if you shouldn't be talking about this, right? If you shouldn't
be talking about this at all, hey, um they'll uh they'll just
let you know how you should talk or sorry, if you can talk about
this in a narrow way, they'll like narrow it down for you how
you should talk about it. The fact that Banell's rule 11 motion
fails to address the issue these issues further highlights the
improper purpose of the motion. Plaintiff cross moves for rule
11 sanctions. By separate motion, plaintiff will seek rule 11
sanctions for forcing her to respond to defendants's frivolous
rule 11 motion filed for an improper purpose. Rule 11 authorizes
a court to sanction a party who submits a pleading for an improper
purpose. As such, the filing of a mo of motion uh a motion for
sanctions and it is itself subject to the requirements of the
rule and can lead to sanctions.
Okay. Okay. Uh I super don't like care about these arguments
to be honest with you like for for the sanctions specifically.
It's like not really that relevant to the case in my opinion.
And
yeah, I just I I super don't care man. Um, do I Who do I think
is going to win
I don't know. It's It's pretty close. I do think that some of
this is like factual dispute. I think I I don't have like a strong
feeling either way. Have not been given a strong feeling either
way. What going on here? Hold on. Some of pinging me for. What
are you pinging me for? You loser.
You meowies.
Don't ping me. I think they're both going to be denied. Yeah.
I just I don't I have no strong opinion on this. It doesn't seem
it it just seems like people spending money to spend money. It's
a little unfortunate.
Although I would say that given that Pixie thing is like, hey,
this is like wrong to do and it's just costing me money to respond
to. Does that not make if if the first one gets dismissed, if
Destiny's gets dismissed, does that not make Pixie stronger?
As in like, hey, your is weak and the entire argument of the
other sanctions is that this is weak and like not meritorious
at all? I don't know. I don't know, man. Oh, and then there's
a notice of like a mediator hearing. So apparently there's a
mediation December 22nd, right before Christmas. Good times.
Um, this can be court mandated sometimes,
right? Like basically if you guys are having a hard time getting
through anything,
I think a judge can basically say you guys have to go to med
mediation. Got to figure it out. Um, yeah. Try to pound town.
You're like here really worried about, how do I put this? Whether
or not Pixie wins this case. Like you understand that the actual
moral wrongs involved in everything going on here have happened
outside of the courtroom are not even needing to be adjudicated
anymore. Like that Destiny's already guilty of the actual moral
wrongs here. Like we're we're not really concerned. Pixie could
get awarded $0 or a million dollars. It doesn't make Destiny
any more or less morally culpable for his actions. We understand
this. Yes. I'm just I'm just letting you know that like some
people might argue the case is strong, but it doesn't mean that
that's like should be the argument or anything.
Right. Okay.
All right. We're just about ready to go on to the the Destiny
Cope. Let's see what he has to say. Again,
as far as like the legal case goes, I super don't give a I like
actually just super don't I I don't care how this turns out.
I just see Desty being a total psycho outside of this case, right?
Like his actions were were totally degenerate. He was totally
in the wrong. He tried to apologize a little bit. Tried to lie
to make people feel sorry for him. and it's kind of blown up
in his face. Now he has this court case going. However this court
case goes, I don't care. His actions like outside of the court
case are what are actually showing him to be a totally degenerate
psychopath, right? He's threatening to dox his former friends
for nothing more than just being like, "Hey, this guy probably
needs some help. This guy's kind of [__] up.
It's goofy. It's goofy." Anyway, yeah.
I don't know. My my thoughts on this case have been since I want
to say April, March, March, April have been that like it seems
unlikely. It's just going to come down to discovery. If Pixie
can get the Discord logs,
it's that's literally been my opinion. It's like if she doesn't
get the Discord logs, I think she's got a 0% chance of winning.
She gets the Discord logs from Destiny, like the sorry, from
uh Discord themselves. If she can subpoena Discord and get the
logs via Discord, then
I think she's got a shot. As other than that, it's it's like
over. So, I've thought probably decent chance she loses from
the very beginning or sorry, from probably April. Anyway,
let me go take a look at what I got for time stamps because I
got some time stamps from his stream. Let's see if we can check
them out.